there are three challenges in the three
main challenges in machine learning the
first one is
you know getting machines to learn to
represent the world
and proposing self-supervised learning
the second is
getting machines to reason in ways that
are compatible with
essentially gradient-based learning
because this is what deep learning is
all about really
and the third one is something we have
no idea how to solve at least i have no
idea to solve is
can we get machines to learn
hierarchical representations of action
plans
you know like you know we know how to
train them to learn hierarchical
representations of perception
you know with convolutional nets and
things like that and transformers but
what about action plans can we uh get
them to spontaneously learn good
hierarchical representations of actions
also gradient based
yeah all of that has you know needs to
be somewhat differentiable so that you
can apply sort of gradient-based
learning uh which is really what deep
running is about
so it's background
knowledge ability to reason in a way
that's differentiable that
is somehow connected deeply integrated
with that background knowledge or builds
on top of that background knowledge and
then given that background knowledge be
able to make hierarchical plans right in
the world so if if you take classical
optimal control there's something in
classical optimal control called uh
model predictive control
and it's you know it's been around since
the early 60s
nasa uses that to compute trajectories
of rockets and the basic idea is that
you have a pretty predictive model
of the rocket let's say or whatever
system you are you intend to control
which
given the state of the system at time t
and given an action
that you are taking on the system so for
rocket to be thrust and you know all the
controls you can have
it gives you the state of the system at
time t plus delta t right so basically a
differential equation something like
that
um
and if you have this model and you have
this model
in the form of some sort of neural net
or some sort of uh set of formula that
you can back propagate gradient through
you can do what's called model
predictive control or gradient based
uh model predictive control so you have
uh you can unroll that
that model in time you you
you you feel it a
hypothesized sequence of actions
and then you have some objective
function that measures how well at the
end of the trajectory the system has
succeeded or matched what you wanted to
do
um you know is it a robot harm have you
grasped the object you want to grasp if
it's a rocket you know are you at the
right place near the space station
things like that
and by back propagation through time and
again this was invented in the 1960s by
optimal control theorists
you can figure out uh what is the
optimal sequence of actions that will
uh you know get my system to the
the best final state
so
that's a form of reasoning it's
basically planning and a lot of planning
systems in robotics are actually based
on this
and uh
and you can think of this as a form of
reasoning so you know to take the
example of the teenager driving a car
again you have a pretty good dynamical
model of the car it doesn't need to be
very accurate but you know again that if
you
turn the wheel to the right and there is
a cliff you're going to run off the
cliff right you don't need to have a
very accurate model to predict that
and you can run this in your mind and
decide not to do it for that reason
because you can predict in advance that
the result is going to be bad so you can
sort of imagine different scenarios
and uh and then you know employ
uh or take the first step in the
scenario that is most favorable and then
repeat the process of planning that's
called receding horizon model predictive
control so even you know all those
things have names you know
going back you know decades
and so
if you're not not a you know classical
optimal control the model of the world
is not generally learned
there's you know sometimes a few
parameters you have to identify that's
called systems identification but
but generally
the model is
mostly deterministic and mostly built by
hand so the big question of ai i think
the big challenge of ai for the next
decade
is how do we get machines to learn
predictive models of the world that deal
with uncertainty and deal with the real
world in all this complexity so it's not
just the trajectory of a rocket which
you can reduce to first principles it's
not it's not even just a trajectory of a
robot arm which again you can model by
you know careful mathematics but it's
everything else everything you observe
in the world you know people behavior
you know physical systems that involve
collective phenomena
like water or or you know
trees and you know branches in a tree or
something or
or uh like complex things that you know
humans have no trouble
developing abstract representations in
predictive model four but we still don't
know how to do with machines where do
you put in in these three maybe in the
in the planning stages
the
the game theoretic nature of this world
where your actions not only respond to
the dynamic nature of the world the
environment but also affected
so if there's other humans involved is
this is this
point number four or is it somehow
integrated into the hierarchical
representation of action in your view i
think it's integrated it's just um it's
just that now your model of the world
has to deal with you know it just makes
it more complicated right the fact that
uh humans are complicated and not easily
predictable
that makes your model of the world much
more complicated that much more
complicated well there's a chat i mean i
suppose chess is an analogy
so uh monte carlo tree search
there is a i go you go i go you go like
uh andre kapatha recently gave a talk at
mit about car doors
i think there's some machine learning
too but mostly car doors and there's a
dynamic nature to the car like the
person opening the door checking
and he wasn't talking about that he was
talking about the perception problem of
what the ontology of what defines a car
door this big philosophical question but
to me it was interesting because like
it's obvious that the person opening the
car doors they're trying to get out like
here in new york trying to get out of
the car
you slowing down it's going to signal
something you speeding up is going to
signal something and that's dance it's a
asynchronous
chess game i don't know
so
it feels like um it's not just i mean i
guess you can integrate all of them into
one giant model like the entirety of the
the
these little interactions because it's
not as complicated as chess it's just
like a little dance we do like a little
dance together and then we figure it out
well in some ways it's way more
complicated than chess because uh
because it's continuous it's uncertain
in a continuous manner
uh it doesn't feel more complicated but
it doesn't feel more complicated because
that's what we're we've evolved to solve
this the kind of problem we've evolved
to solve and so we're good at it because
you know
nature has made us good at it
you